partons pour carnac 1 samedi à la plage
samedi les pieds dans l'eau ils n'ont
encore un peu fraîche l'affluence des
grands jours jacques devaux gabri kenya
à carnac il y à un détail qui ne trompe
pas lorsque le petit train reprend du
service
c'est que les beaux jours arrivent pas
encore déconnecter les vacanciers
s'installe sur les plages et si on vient
en famille souvent depuis des années la
[ __ ] bordeaux mais ça ça dépayse les
enfants aiment bien il aime bien le des
vagues
le simple fait qu'un climat dans ce
petit coin de paradis les plus
téméraires aux mêmes la baignade et la
guinée plus chaudes
n'attendant pas toujours si pour le bain
c'est encore un peu juste pour les
amoureux de voile en revanche l'heure de
la reprise a sonné au large plus de 300
catamaran sillonnent la baie de quiberon
rien que du bonnet plus belles baies
conte auquel on navigue en catamaran
qu'elle a pas protégés avec du vent
aujourd'hui en plus il fait beau et un
vent médium dont colin dès qu'on y sent
qu'ils ont un excellent aujourd'hui mer
calme jolie brise les sensations sont
même accessibles à ceux qui n'ont pas le
pied marin
déjà que les gens prennent plaisir à le
faire et ensuite une fois qu'ils ont
pris plaisir effectivement donné le
virus
souvent les questions qu'on nous pose à
la fin c'est où est-ce qu'on peut
pratiquer dans quelle école de voile on
va le retrouver ce sont ces sensations
là sur un catamaran et pour des vacances
totalement réussi il reste
l'incontournable promenade en rosalie au
prix d'un les gérer fort sur les pédales
quel bonheur d'imposer son rythme aux
automobilistes qui n'osent même pas que
l'actionnaire